Tom Hanks is starring in his third Dan
Brown movie directed by Ron Howard the
first to The DaVinci Code and angels and
demons have made more than 1.2 billion
dollars and now we are taking you behind
the scenes of infirm and action
Tom Hanks returns as Robert Langdon but
this time the professor who always has
the answers has amnesia I want to know
what I'm at fault with why was someone
shooting at you everything is out of
focus I have no memory of taking that
man someone's after him in trying to
kill him so he wants to avoid being shot
by a number of assassins that's bad film
also stars oscar-nominated actress
Felicity Jones who found herself
fangirling on sent over her two-time
Academy Award winning leading man he's
so incredibly professional and it's easy
on set and joking and laughing and it's
been really really wonderful working
with him they're gonna wipe out half the
world's population unless we find this
virus also back again are some big
stunts and of course beautiful locations
filming in Italy and all across Europe
it has an incredible international cast
and you move across the world all
different locations and I think it'll
just be
right to be on when you're watching me
Langdon and company are constantly
having to rush from one place to the
next
the professor has become a liability
let's get it don't seem to figure about
there's always way now Dante better move
over though because Felicity Jones who
you just saw there she's gonna be hotter
than hot at the end of the year Inferno
comes out in October and then rogue one
a Star Wars story comes out in these
neighborhoods are already going crazy
about this they go crazy for everything
star that is correct